hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar investigating how TPC 1 may be
used as a novel therapeutic agent in the
treatment of human hematologic cancers
presented by Jessica house PhD student
the University of Texas at El Paso my
name is Chrissy Jewell and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
laberd's and brought to you by thermo
Fisher Scientific for more information
on our sponsor please visit thermo
Fisher comm forward slash cell culture
heroes now before we get started I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send we will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation now if you
have any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation use that ask a question box
to let us know you're experiencing a
problem this presentation is educational
and those offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located at the top
right of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits I now present today's speaker
Jessica Hesse PhD student the University
of Texas at El Paso for a complete
biography on Jessica please visit the
biography tab at the top of your screen
Jessica you may now begin your
presentation
hello everyone my name is Jessica Hut
I'm a PhD student in the Department of
Biological Sciences at the University of
Texas at El Paso and today I'll be
discussing my experimental compounds tpz
one and its development as a potential
therapeutic agent and the treatment of
blood cancer
in this webinar I'll start off by
sharing a bit about myself some cancer
statistics discuss current challenges of
chemotherapy then walk you through the
initial process of identifying novel
cancer killing compounds via
high-throughput screening and cell based
assays I'll be using cheap easy one as
an example throughout my work on PPC
what one is very much ongoing so I'll
conclude with some future directions for
this project and leave those of you new
to cell culture with some useful tips
that have helped me along the way I hope
you enjoy this presentation on my
research and I look forward to answering
some of your questions at the end
so hello and thank you for your time
that's me Jessica and I'm just starting
my second year in dr. Vanessa Aguilera's
lab where I'm working to find novel
cancer-killing compounds prior to
starting my PhD I earned my bachelor's
degree in chemistry from Virginia
Commonwealth University and worked as a
nursing assistant on a pediatric medical
surgical unit I actually had no formal
lab experience when I started my PhD
journey my motivation to pursue cancer
research was largely because I have a
strong family history of cancer
diagnosis in a random twist of fate my
family is originally from El Paso so I
feel extremely fortunate to have the
opportunity to study cancer here I've
really grown to love what I do and I
couldn't be more excited to talk about
my project today
when I'm not in the lab you'll find me
designing science team stickers and
stationery for my business cell culture
co which I started back in January of
this year after creating a fun logo for
our lab if you're interested in seeing
more of my art you can find the complete
catalogue of my creations at cell
culture cocom in addition to my art I
enjoy sharing my PhD experience and a
little bit of science through social
media primarily through Instagram and
Twitter I'm very very excited to be this
month's cell culture hero because as you
may have guessed cell culture is truly
one of my favorite parts of my job
moving on to cancer statistics this year
in the United States the American Cancer
Society expects approximately 1.7
million new cancer cases stop the
equivalent of over 4,800 cases each day
they also predict around 600,000 cancer
deaths of these new cases and deaths
lymphoma myeloma and leukemia will be
responsible for about 10% this is why
the development of novel treatments for
these cancers is important and why these
blood cancers will be the stars of this
presentation
the specific cancer treatment a patient
will receive depends on the type of
cancer they have and if it has spread
and Blair but most often patients
receive chemotherapy in conjunction with
other treatments unfortunately many
chemo therapies have highly toxic side
effects that leads to things like hair
loss nerve damage and GI issues some
effects can even persist for years or be
permanent
depending on a person's tolerance for
these side-effects they can really limit
clinicians from using effective drug
doses to treat their cancer
in addition cancer cells are constantly
acquiring new mutations and finding a
way to evade death so drug resistance is
a recurring issue there's a continuous
need for good novel cancer therapies
which address these challenges and are
more targeted towards cancer cells
knowing this the lab I work in conducts
high-throughput compound screening to
identify novel compounds which are
effective in killing cancer cells and
will hopefully kill them via protein
target that is expressed primarily in
cancer
high throughput screening is a method
used to analyze large compound library
in an initial compound screening I can
test up to 80 individual compounds in
one 96-well plate at this stage I only
use one concentration typically 5 micro
molar the purpose of the initial screen
is just to identify compounds with the
ability to kill 50% or more of the cells
after a compound has been identified in
an initial screening I test it again in
a secondary screenings of confirm its
activity at this stage I treat cells
with a gradient of the compound to
calculate a dc50 or the concentration of
the drug which kills 50 percent of the
cells drugs with 50 50s in the nano
molar range are typically what I look
for so if a drug has a low cc 50 I'll
start working my way through cell based
assays to try and clarify its mechanism
of action
the differential nuclear staining assay
is a live cell imaging technique that I
use to determine cytotoxicity it
requires seating myself into a 96-well
plates exposing those cells to a drug
which in my case is TPP one and leaving
them to incubate usually for 24 to 72
hours then I come back and I add two
nuclear dyes called pokes and propidium
iodide and then acquire cell images I
use the GE in cell analyzer 2000 and
finally after I take those images I
analyze them to quantify at a living and
dead cell population this assay works by
distinguishing these populations based
on membrane integrity hooks is a dice
capable of permeating the membrane of
all cells in my samples whereas
propidium iodide will only permeate
those cells with compromised membrane
therefore Koko localization excuse me of
the two dives is representative of the
dead cell population I use this assay in
primary high-throughput screening as
well as when I'm retesting the compounds
to find a 50/50
now I'd like to introduce you to cheap
easy one unfortunately I can't show you
the full structure at this time but I
can tell you that it's a cyano Kyra's
old derivative this compound is special
because cyano parables are a largely
unexplored class of compounds which
generates less than 10 results when I
search the term on PubMed
however the publication's associated
with these compounds identify them as
effective antioxidants and to tumor
agents and kinase inhibitors
I found this compound while conducting a
high-throughput screening projects of
over 2,000 compounds and I've been
working with it ever since all the data
I'm about to show you has not yet been
published but merits the continued study
of tpz 1 and its potential as an
anti-cancer agent
in the table shown you'll find the CC
50s I calculated by testing TP z1
against the panel of human blood cancers
as well as one non-tumor genic cell line
PPC one demonstrated potent cytotoxicity
in the NIP nano molar to low micromolar
range against all the cancer cell lines
by used interesting ly enough the
cytotoxic effect was greatly diminished
upon testing TP z1 against the non
cancer cell line because of its low CC
50 and my familiarity with the stem cell
line this cell line was selected for use
in subsequent assays to determine if TPP
wine kill cells via apoptosis apoptosis
is a form of programmed cell death which
involves the controlled dismantling of
intracellular components avoiding
inflammation than damage to surrounding
cells all of the assays I will discuss
from this point on were analyzed by flow
cytometry
Sothis experiment I conducted was in an
x + 5 v CP is a to determine if
phosphatidyl syrian was being
externalized phosphatidyl serine which
is normally present on the inner leaflet
of the plasma membrane is flipped to the
cell surface during the early stages of
able ptosis in the body this serves as
an Eaton signal prompting phagocytes to
engulf the film annexin v is a cellular
protein with high affinity for
phosphatidylserine
if Sora sent 50 conjugate was used to
selectively label cells undergoing
apoptosis in contrast propidium iodide
was used to detect necrosis because it
will only permeate the cells which have
lost their membrane integrity total
apoptosis was calculated by summing
early apoptotic and late april tot Excel
population which are both an X and 5:50
positive and can be either P I positive
or negative the in xn v fitzy negative
but p i+ population is representative of
necrosis the result of this athlete
demonstrate that CPC one treatment
preferentially induces cell death by
apoptosis
next I went down to a caspase-3 acid
test phases or proteases which play an
essential role in apoptosis initiator
cafes as their name implies initiate
apoptosis they go on to activate
executioner cast spaces such as cast
phase three which then go on to demolish
key structural proteins leading to the
classes apoptosis morphological features
such as DNA fragmentation and membrane
blebbing TPP one treatment elicited dose
dependent half these three activation at
eight hours further implying that cell
death occurs by apoptosis
next I evaluated the accumulation of
reactive oxygen species and cells
treated with TPP one reactive oxygen
species are indicative of oxidative
stress and could mean that mitochondria
are being affected tpz one treatments
behaves similarly to my positive control
hydrogen peroxide and induce significant
Roth accumulation in cells after 18
hours of exposure the next step after
conducting this experiment is typically
a jc1 assay which detects changes in
mitochondrial membrane potential and I
performed a JC 1fa but my results were
inconclusive
so it's still not clear to me if my
cells are dying via the intrinsic a
by-product pathway
finally I examine the effects of TP z1
on the cell cycle this assay works by
using DNA binding dyes that bind in
proportion to the amount of DNA present
in the cell
therefore cells in S phase will take up
more dye than cells in g1 but left them
cells in the g2 phase when compared with
the profile of untreated and DMSO
treated cells TPP one treatment caused
significant dose-dependent disruption
it's important to note this accumulation
of cells in the sub G 0 g1 phase was
observed and odd
fragmentation due to apoptosis
currently I'm working on my first
manuscript for TPP one and then in the
process of sorting through transcriptome
data the transcriptome provides me with
the gene expression profile of cancer
cells after treating them with TPP one
and will help me in piecing together Tsz
ones function and deciding which assays
I should perform next also in the future
I'll be looking into some structural
analogues of TPP one to compare their
cytotoxic activity and also assessing
TPP one against more cancer types and
non-tumor genic cell line to determine
if my compound is it all selective
towards one type verse another
for those of you just starting cell
culture don't worry there's lots of
resources out there to get you started
for any general cell line information
you may need and culturing methods I
recommend checking out the American type
culture collection website shown here
for also culture based get basics give
Co has you covered with virtual labs
tutorials and handbooks which are really
useful if you're a hands-on learner like
me my personal advice I'll leave you
with is this one seek the advice of
colleagues with experience culturing the
cell lines you'll be using they'll be
able to really tell you if they used an
alternative media from not listed in a
PCC or if they had any struggles and
maintaining viability of their culture
to be prepared to spend lots of time
getting to know yourself
each cell line is unique some prefer to
be in closer proximity while others like
to be more spread out some cells do well
with pathogen every two or three days
while others I've had the passage almost
daily
three consider how the cells in your
culture are communicating with each
other when you're passing them viability
can be really hard to recover if you
accidentally over dilute them so it's
better to err on the side of caution and
lastly always handle yourself carefully
and while using your best aseptic
technique I always make sure to visually
inspect my cells before and after
handling them this way I can spot any
contaminants weird morphology changes
and see if I have diluted myself to a
suitable density and with that I
conclude my presentation and I'd like to
extend a special thank you to everyone
that has helped me thus far especially
those mentioned here I'd now like to
open it up to questions so please feel
free to ask the way
Thank You Jessica for your informative
presentation now we will start the live
Q&A portion of our webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on that ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen and we will answer as many of
your questions that we have time for
okay let's get started and while we've
got some great questions coming in
alright just collect start with this
question here how does the differential
nuclear staining essay differ from more
common cytotoxicity assays such as mts
and why does your lab use it
Thank You Christy that's a great
question MPs uses enzymatic activity to
measure viability
whereas DMS measures viability based on
membrane integrity my lab uses it
because it only has a few steps most of
which are simple we don't have to wash
cells or manipulate them really at all
after they've been seated so first I
plate the cells and then I apply my
treatment and then I just pop them in
the incubator until I'm ready to add
dyes and then once I add the dyes I wait
for two hours image them and I'm able to
segment those images using a software
that gives me an excel sheet that will
tell me percentages of living in dead
cells one of the limitations would be
the high cost of the equipment we're
really fortunate to have a high content
analyzers like the GE insole which
automates the imaging process for us it
uses a 10x objective to capture a 2 by 2
montage on two different fluorescent
channels at once so we're able to
visualize thousands of cells versus the
few hundred that would be possible with
manual counting
ESCA now can you share with us what are
your plans for when you graduate are you
so hoping to pursue cell culture
um ideally yes I really find it
enjoyable I like the challenge of
getting to know all my different cell
lines as I mentioned in my tip they're
all kind of different so when I first
saw some cells out I check on them every
day really and I really kind of try and
get to know how fast they divide you
know how confluent they like to be and
that can sometimes be a real challenge
so I hope to continue doing cell based
assays I would like to continue in
cancer research as well
now can you please explain why you
selected DMSO as a control
so demo saw serves as my vehicle
controls it's what I dissolve TP z1 in
some drugs don't dissolve in PBS or
saline and mine is a prime example so I
have to use DMSO
you know the question for you here uh
why can you not reveal the structure of
TPC one
well everything I presented today is
unpublished I'm in the process of
piecing together the first draft of my
manuscript but it's been kind of a slow
process for me because it's my first
time and also I'm not sure if the
structure has been patented or not so
that may be looked into in the future as
well
Thank You Jessica now can you please
elaborate on how the reactive oxygen
species sa xetex ro s
okay so the Roth I'll say uses a cell
type permeable dye that generates green
fluorescence when it interacts with
reactive oxygen species
I usually treat my cells with my 24
hours CC 50 that I've calculated and
twice that concentration and then I
incubate for 18 hours for assessing for
the reactive oxygen species
here's a great question now just like to
share with us do you have any advice for
a new PhD student entering their program
with no experience in the field
um try not to get caught up and feeling
like you're behind because you may be
started off with less knowledge than
your peers I mean I believe that I was
accepted to my program for a reason
and that's true for everyone that's been
accepted to a ph.d program they really
saw some potential in you so just be
patient with yourself and give yourself
plenty of time to review and get used to
grad school in general it's a huge
change from being an undergrad or you
know just having a job in general and it
kind of helps but it's a lot more
enjoyable to study and learn because
you're finally being taught all the
things that you've probably wanted to
learn about your whole life that's
helped
thank you for that let's go back to -
busy's does tpz 1 share any similarities
with other lead compounds your group has
identified
um as far as I know my compound has a
pretty unique structure
it also looks different than the other
active compounds
I found within my own high-throughput
screening I did find a couple others
which just so happened to be analogs of
some other compounds river can but I
can't I I haven't really seen a similar
structure if you look for recent
publications with Renato Jay Aguilera as
an author you can see some of the
compounds that we've found recently and
also learn a little bit more about the
athletes that I discussed today because
we all follow a similar initial
screening process
Thank You Jessica now have any final
comments for our audience
um yes I just wanted to thank Jim Coan
lab roots so much for this opportunity
especially you Christy and Chelsea for
your guidance
and to everyone in the audience for
taking the time to watch my first ever
presentation on my research um if you
have any questions or you'd like to
collaborate um please feel free to
contact me via social media my handle is
cell culture Co you can message me
through my website so culture cocom or
email me at cell culture co at gmail.com
um and I would suggest that you all
check my website after this presentation
for a little celebration sale and
finally I just wanted to go back to
these cell culture tips um I really
really recommend copying down these
websites and using them for all things
cell culture we actually use the virtual
labs in our facility to kind of help
train the Orion T's Gladys was kind
enough to show me exactly the ones that
she sent yesterday and I was kind of
surprised to see it's on this exact same
page as the cell culture heroes so keep
an eye out for that
Thank You Jessica now I want to thank
our audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions with
great questions coming in now the
questions that we did not have time for
today and those that continue to commit
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by Jessica via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration now Jessica would like to
thank you today for your time and for
your interim for your important research
I would also like to thank lab roots and
I'd like to thank our sponsor by thermo
Fisher Scientific for underwriting
today's educational webcast
now this webcast can be viewed on demand
and laboratory
via email when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now we
hope to see you again soon have a great
day